so I auditioned for 70s and the
character is supposed to be 14 but in
all television they want you to be
legally emancipated so you can work
longer hours and so I must have at one
point said something to the extent of
yeah they're like are you 18 I must have
been like yeah sure I was clear if you
watch a pilot I am clearly a child but
it's smart I mean in in Show Business
they say if somebody if somebody ask
when I filled out the paperwork for like
the what like the producer call like
towards the very end I was like oh by
the way I need a studio teacher and they
were like wait come again if somebody if
somebody says to they say in Show
Business can you ski you just say yes I
can ski and then you go figure it out I
didn't know how to swim until so untiled
a movie called piranha and they were
like can you swim and I was like totally
I can swim with piranha no problem yeah
piranha don't eat me yeah